I know this
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to ha run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
[Music]
one okay so look I mean we know the the
the social media world world Hollywood
Sports business politics is filled with
uh many amateur Trolls but there's some
professional trolls there are some that
are comfortable trolling others and
getting under their skin Our Guest today
is an expert in that but before I'm sure
he's been a great troll his entire life
knowing how to piss people off he's had
an incredible interesting unique career
Higher Learning I remember watching
Higher Learning was in Higher Learning
he dated Phoebe guys dated Phoebe on
Friends if I'm not mistaken True Romance
he was at uh Brad Pitt's wedding with
Jennifer Aniston seeing the wall of
caviar and there's a bunch of different
things he's got his own podcast called I
am Rappaport stereo podcast but the most
disturbing thing about all the facts
that I learned about him this this one
made me feel a little bit UNC we were
actually a little bit hesitant about
inviting him after I heard about this he
is obsessed I mean absolutely obsessed
with u The Real Housewives and and
that's concerning you know when you hear
somebody that knows so much about it
with that being said wrap a port in the
house how you doing man how you feeling
good to be here appreciate you having me
big fan big fan of the show um and
excited to be here I love it I love it
it's I know you were talking right off
the bat you said you know the unveiling
right the Kobe Bryant oning you of the
statue cuz today when we're recording uh
uh two uh
824 so I'm sure that had something to do
with it and and I had first really saw
you when you had done that interview
that uh you know we still see clips from
with uh the late great Kobe Bryant so
that's kind of what my introduction to
you and I'm a fan of the show so I'm
excited to be here I got to find a
locker if there's any space left and
Rapaport you travel with a pitpull yes
you're beautiful wife AKA Pitbull came
in here and just it's a beautiful she
she she laid the law
we're we're F said don't you mess with
my husband y'all well she didn't say
y'all but but she I threw that one in
there Michael we can have but my my
mother-in-law is a fan of the show and
uh we watch yeah we watch the show we
watch the show yeah I mean she came she
straight up went for Vinnie oh yeah
mother-in-law went for Vinnie you go
talk to that man anyways but you know we
all know one thing about Vinnie what's
that he's from Yonkers he's you're from
y with he got stabbed by his mother
stabbed him with a butter knife hey it
might have been a wooden spoon that was
cracked but listen I got a gun so I'm
from Yonkers before we get into it so
last time on Tuesday we announce anybody
that buys uh uh the future looks bright
hats in the gear and we said we want a
million people we in this gear during
these strange times we want people
walking around saying hey I believe
future looks right and getting the
reaction from other people when you wear
that shirt we have some stuff that we
haven't given away we're continuing this
we sold out of a couple of our hats by
the way on Tuesday instantly Three Hats
sold out but anybody that buys any of
these gears Rob can we show this on the
camera so people can see it pick any one
of these hats and one of the future
looks bright shirts okay go a little
lower you got the purple one you got the
white one pick any of these trucker hats
for some of you guys that want the vam
logo with US flag next to it we also got
the pbd podcast hat there as well you
pick the black or white future looks
bright hat choose any of these
combination hat and a shirt you do next
week what we're doing is will be giving
away uh one of the Ryan Garcia signed
gloves a Trevor Bower signed ball and
five signed choose your enemies wisely
live next Thursday next Tuesday at the
end of the podcast for home team having
said that let's get right into it where
do the hardest people come out of from
New York like when you typically think I
mean listen it ain't where you're from
it's where you're at to quote the uh the
great uh Rock Kim Eric being and rock
Kim so I mean you know there there's
there's tough people from everywhere and
there's soft people from everywhere but
you know historically the Bronx uh uh uh
in Brooklyn I would say historically uh
probably the the most and you know a lot
of Fighters come from Brooklyn you know
Mike Tyson um rck Bo I mean there's zap
Judah you know Jake lamat from the Bronx
so it all it all and where you from
where'd you grow I'm from Manhattan grew
up in New York City that's not the
hardest right definitely not the hardest
but you know you know they say Brooklyn
keeps on taking it uh Bronx keeps
creating it uh uh Queens keeps on Faking
it and Manhattan keeps on making it
we're known for the money so you know
what rapper was that who said that keeps
taking what a great line by the way ks1
okay um krs1 boogie down Productions say
it again so so say say the four again
Brooklyn
keep go Vinnie go ahead Vinnie you're
from yers I I I love the this Yonkers
thing ain't going nowhere DMX was
Yonkers town is right next to the Bronx
it's Yonkers right so we're that far
like we're so far away that by the way
you know who's from Yonkers DMX the
locks jiss uh Mary J BL and Vinnie and
Vinnie and people act like they don't
know like Yonkers is on the map by like
you said he's like it ain't where you're
from it's where you're at I'm right
finish the line from ks1 don't
disrespect Brooklyn keeps on making it
no Brooklyn keeps on taking it Bronx
keeps creating it Queens keeps on Faking
It Manhattan keeps on making it I did it
out of order anyway so Queens is faking
then this is in a hip-hop line I didn't
say get me in trouble now Queens is
going to come after him they they know
the line it's a it's an iconic hip hop
line anyway Michael who were you in high
school who who were you 14 15 years old
I'm a I'm a classmate of yours if we
interviewed five your classmate that
spent the most time with you who was
Michael rer very good question I
was uh talking no uh
basketball uh uh hoop
dream having hip
hop
loving um very gregarious kid who was
exploring um you know all of New York
and but my focus was was basketball and
and and and hipop and just you know I
was just out and about man but I that's
a that's a good question but I was
that's who I was I was very very
disruptive I got kicked out of school
from the third grade to the 12th grade I
went from a different School literally
from the third grade to the 12th grade
and I went
to public school in New York City um I
went to arasmus Hall High School which
is in Brooklyn New York and uh got
kicked out of there and there were
violent criminals in there and they
asked me to leave after my 11th grade
year just because they said you're told
my father you're just such a pain in the
ass no there was no incident there was
no fires being set which one is you
which which one is who's that picture
he's the black guy yeah no that's magic
that's Magic Johnson yeah so that was
about 13 years old but I mean you know I
wanted to be a basketball player and I
just was big disruptive personality and
you know was you know had a unique sort
of uh uh period of time between you know
19 between when I was 12 and 19 cuz I
was everywhere uh uh except for home
Michael when did you realize you could
monetize and capitalize on being this
gregarious
larger to be honest with you figure out
the money you know you said the word
Troll and and and I don't I don't um I
don't particularly like that term and I
certainly don't consider myself that
because my social
media presence and the things that sort
of ruffle feathers people excite people
love people don't love on social media
are never never premeditated ever ever
ever ever so when you know I feel like
that term troll is is is is the way you
were using it I don't think it was
disrespectful I think it's like you're
sort of doing a concerted effort to
excite and and entice and excite and I
and I don't and I think if I did do that
I wouldn't be as good at it and and if I
did do that I probably could monetize
monetize from it but but like my social
media stuff that that have um that has
went viral that people talk about good
batter and different whether it's Sports
whether it's hip-hop whether it's
political um it's always off the cuff
it's never pre pre-planned and
premeditated like it's it's literally I
just go which which one got you in the
most trouble what what did you say that
got the most eyeballs and reaction was a
politics sports or hip-hop man there's
probably one of each man if I if I went
through one of each I I could tell you
that there's there's been a lot of
sports over the years it's been a lot of
hip-hop over the years and it's been a
lot of politics over the years honestly
there's if I if I went over each one it
it's across the board but you know um
the the the the one the introduction to
my I could say talk because I I
don't want to yeah you're fine my
introduction to talking outside of
sports
and music was after
Charlottesville um it was a Saturday
morning after the you will not replace
this Jews will not replace this and when
I was living in Los Angeles I would take
that that video I would take my dog out
for walks and I was
so taken aback that people whatever year
that was 2017a public no I think it was
16 was that the year Trump trump was
started in 16 yeah but the election was
in 16 November 16 but he was sworn in
January 2017 yeah charville it was 201
July or June of 17 summer of 2017 you're
right and I was so offended that people
would publicly say Jews will not replace
us as if we gave a about those tiki
torch khaki pants wearing disenfranchise
people as if the Jewish people are
trying to replace you Los
and just to speak that out loud I was
like and that video went crazy viral and
it was I think a a minute and like I you
know my dog is in it and I'm just
walking it's literally 8 play play for a
second I want to see what which one this
is last night in Charlottesville
Virginia a bunch of white nationalists
carrying tiki torches that they got from
Home Depot wearing skinny jeans drinking
coffee came out for a protest saying
White lives matter why life matter you
know your life ain't if you're a
college student on a Friday night during
the summertime you ain't getting no ass
and you decide to come out for a protest
carrying tiki torches talking
little coffee cup carrying white
nationalists you ain't if you was
really trying to get it popping you
would have taken your little Ed shearing
protest right over there at the Virginia
Beach or Newport News and you would have
got your tiki torches stuffed up your
ass revenge of the nerd protesters eat
some pizza take take a few bong rips
don't you got a toga party to go
to it's Friday night try to get to
second base with a girl you
loser talking about white lives matter
White lives matter throwing up Nazi
salutes dorm room dumb but I bet
you your dog is like why is Dad tripping
the dog is like Dad that was that
was my my dog passed my that was my
dog's Comfort Comfort uh uh tone oh
really so on our walks like he would be
like oh he's doing a video but but that
at that time just went crazy crazy crazy
viral but like I said I I I never
contrive the stuff it's just sort of
happen and Mike where is that cuz a lot
like my my father was was like a
composer music my sister plays classical
I played the trumpet but I'm also a wise
ass funny cuz I would my father would
make us Entertainer fromont people where
did you get that that Brash who gives a
attitude was it family was it just
from the streets where did you pick it
up that's just how I came out man that's
it that's just how I came out I mean you
know it's it's it's just how I came out
and and um I've always sort of talked a
lot of stuff I'm try not to curse and
I've always you know uh um you know sort
of been good with my mouth you know uh
um and uh I wasn't as good uh uh you
know shooting the ball as I was with my
mouth uh uh you know as far as talking
it's kind of like a superpower
especially you know when you're you know
you're hanging out in the street you
know like some people could fight uh
some people could play ball some people
you know were like you know doing
criminal stuff I was a good like
snapping we call it snapping that was my
thing and and and that particular thing
I um that's not me that I was about to
say I like I was like who the hell is
that next one is my high school Martin
Luther King High School uh yeah zoom
in yeah that was my my my my my last
high school that's you the that's
hilarious that's me there yep yep yep
punch in a little bit Rob let's see our
guy you're a lefty Lefty Lefty and you
see like everybody's ser and I'm this is
me that is that's who you said who I who
was I that's that's who I was there's
like one white person in the entire
place in je Michael you're you're what
53 52 how old are you 53 53 why does
this look like it's from 1920s what's
going it's all black and white black and
white film scho pictures man this is
this isn't the 80s dog 1988 man were you
any good were you a good basketball
player I was a good player but I mean
the levels change so quick when you get
to like 14 15 16 the the you know people
are going through puberty the the the
the the Gap gets quick for for from you
know young teenage sports like you go
from at 14 it's a gap like that and so
you but I had fun and I learned so much
from the camaraderie of playing ball and
the you know it wasn't so much the games
it was the going to the games on the
trains it was the coming back from the
games it was the practice and it was
everything in between and I just I just
loved it but it kept me in line and I
was always I had a goal even though I
didn't reach that goal I had a a goal so
I got so much from you know wanting to
be a professional any of these guys make
it to the did anybody make it from your
high school to the next level or no not
from that high school but I played with
I mean Kenny Anderson you know and left
he's a lefty point guard I mean one of
the best New York players and you know I
would go to basketball camps with Sean
Kemp and Billy Owens and you know Billy
Owens Golden State Warriors exactly so
yeah the Rain Man Sean Kamp yeah so the
Gap you know and that's when I saw that
Gap it was it was very Who was the
craziest guy you saw in the gym like in
high school level was it Kemp was it was
it Sean Kemp when I was at the Five-Star
Basketball Camp was Sean Kemp that you
saw with the Seattle suic no sh at what
age 18 literally it was amazing and and
Kenny Anderson we
knew everybody in New York knew and I I
played one-on-one with Kenny and I was
good TW 12 you could be better than
people I was bigger than Kenny um and
Kenny Anderson at 11 years old
was going to the NBA everybody in New
York knew it at 11 years old he the way
he handled the ball it's like some
people are just gifted you know other
people work at it Kenny Anderson was
just like you know um um you know a
prodigy he was a basketball Prodigy the
way he handled the ball at when I first
saw him at 11 he already had a
reputation at 11 you know like and this
is when it's earned there's no social
media so I saw a bunch of guys you know
I played with a bunch of great players
in New York the late great Malik cely
was another one um Chris Mills you know
I was in the high school with him the
one year I went to school of Fairfax
Chris Mills and Sean Kemp and you know I
was around you know great players and a
time you could play with them but you're
not as good as them but you could play
with them so it was a it was a it was a
great time it was a great time didn't
you have a thing with Brian scalabrini
at one point what was that what was all
that all fun that's my guy okay that's
your guy the white M the white mamb come
on the white M it's like the white mamaa
and Vinnie from yers thank
you I saw some of that people started
challenging scalabrini right to
one-on-one did you see all this
scalabrini could beat any one of your
listeners one-on-one now and he'll tell
you he probably can't and he could the
worst the person who's playing in the
NBA uh uh who's on the 12th man yes
could beat every single one of the
people watching this show I mean it's n
it's a professional basketball player so
the level is just you know who's your
favorite guy who's your favorite guy in
the NBA all time I know you you know you
I think you did something with Earl
Monroe years back but who's your
favorite favorite all time man it's hard
to pick one but I I the the the person
who meant the most to me growing up and
and and and like resonated with me as a
kid the most is Dr J that was my like I
had such love for him Magic Johnson and
Larry Bird but doc was like I wasn't
into cartoons I wasn't into you know
marvel I wasn't into Batman Robin I
wasn't into Bruce Le like Dr J was that
to me and to a lot of people like he was
that to me and uh you know throughout
the years I've gotten to meet him and I
participated with him in the big three
and I
have I've been around him so much my
heart still races when I just love him
Lo love him and he meant so much to me
as a kid he was a
superhero what year what what when
you're saying superhero what your when I
were like when he resonated with me 79
80 81 so listen you're you're a
Manhattan guy even though you kind of
look a little Larry birdes I think I've
seen you in a Celtics Jersey before
what's what's up with your Knicks bro
we're getting better man I mean what I
mean you're not giving a shout out to
youing you're not you don't got Bernard
King on your list Bernard you he said
one guy I'm just saying you're a
Manhattan guy young L I'm going to tell
you right now I don't want to go too
down the the rabbit hole of of of sports
cuz I know this the show I watch the
show I'm going to say right now BAS on
the trades I'm going to say this right
now right into my camera the Knicks just
picked up a bunch of guys bogdanovich
the New York Knicks February was
February 8th yes February 8th 2024 2024
I'm on the pbd podcast millions of
people watch the New York
Knicks are winning the NBA
Championship this year when you're
out of control this year get hey what's
wrong with that what's by the way well
what I'm saying okay so because of who
because of Jaylen Brunson the the whole
team we have a team the New York Knicks
here I'm not going to say winning the
Knicks are going to the championship I'm
not going to say winning the Knicks are
going to the the championship barring a
a catastrophe Michael raport the Knicks
are going I'm going to ask you the one
question I asked Vinnie every time he
takes a makes an outrageous statement
how much money you want to put on this
raap
aort that the Knicks are going to no
that they're winning a champion he said
going going he said I'll bet you a clean
100 how let's make it a thousand let's
be professional no no no no no no no I
think the odds are on your side though
what are the odds and who
you you got to give 100 100 bucks we I
think that's fair I think that's fair
that's the bet there it is done the Nick
I'm a heat guy bro I know what it's like
to go to Championship you guys are going
that's what they said last year we made
you the championship I was at the game
last night and I sat on the wood and I'm
a Heat fan uh heat culture I respect it
that that was last year it's 2024
uh the trade deadline just came in
before I walked into the studio the
Knicks are going to the champion we have
a $100 bet High I am rapper check this
out this is odds right now 20 it's not
like it's a they haven't even caught up
with what happened five minutes that's
I'm saying that hasn't so it could go
even that's winning the Knicks are going
to the championship the Knicks are
coming out of the East and winning the
and going to the Champion by the way
that's a that's a pretty bold statement
to to make dude I have a John stocks
Jersey still chilling in my so let me
let me ask you what you think about the
whole conversations about LeBron to
Knicks is that like a fairy tale it's
not going to happen La he ain't leaving
La you think the Lakers should trade him
he's Le no they're not trading him he
ain't going anywhere he's L LeBron James
do I think the Lakers no he's the best
player on their team yeah I don't think
he's going anywhere he's LeBron you
don't no you I've seen you with the big
three before you've had some beef before
I've seen you were coaching a team
before yes who have you had beef within
I want to say KD and you had some beef
yeah listen I know you didn't want to
call yourself a troll you talk bro
I talk but do talk and a troll
is two different things okay so you
would label yourself a talker
though the best in the world okay we
established some guidelines here one of
the 100% would you call it yapping what
you call it I call it sna snapping is
the talking is the general
atmosphere what happened with some KD
what happened to some other guys all the
other stuff you saw in the big three
that's just performance art yeah okay no
no yeah okay no no it's all just
performance what was real what was the
real real beef none of the stuff on the
big three was real none what was real I
mean you got to ask me specific in my
life with KD KD that was a whole thing
that that got out of hand that was a DM
thing I mean you could you tell it
better than me I actually dude a lot of
this Michael tell no a lot of this was a
few years ago I remember some was
trending so we're reh hatching some
stuff even you don't when you brought up
the Jews will not replace this type of
thing I remember that from seven years
ago but you know times but we got you
now raport what happened with got the KD
thing was was what it was got into an ug
ugly social media Feud yeah and you pull
Tre treat what does it say tra train of
thoughts
trainer trainer oh all right what was it
the worst fights are the ones that there
was no one to root for that's what we
had yesterday with the nasty Twitter
scuffle between broke out between
netstar Kevin dur
nasty oh the participants here
surprising Durant loves to fight with
people on various social media platforms
the rap repor is often looking for
attention not you Mike with
personalities this volti there was no
warning before the fight report the the
the much uh uh the much regarded and
respected trainer Report with an a at
the end yes well Mike you you posted the
the conversation the DMS what was he
saying in the you were calling him a
snake I remember that he no he was
talking about spitting on me and all
this and and uh you know and
talking distri he mentioned my wife and
I was like no it's not happening got it
so that that was what that was three
years ago I think it was
four what was the resolution with that
you guys squash any beef you see him at
all lately seen him I haven't seen him
no what happens if you saw KD by the way
are you step right to him straight up I
mean out of all the basketball players
and professional athletes physically
he's the one that I would probably be
least concerned about because you
probably way more than him way more than
him at a lean mean 210 lb all right oh
Durant yeah easy money I was at a club I
was at a club mik and I saw this like
he's obviously huge but his he was
wearing he has little baby ankles that
but I'm not a tough guy at all I don't I
don't claim to be I don't want I'm 53
I'm going to be 54 in March yeah and uh
you know St your world no but don't say
that Mike cuz people are going to say oh
that his bark is louder than his bite my
bark is louder than my bite all right
you think this is man so I
talk and I don't I'm not a boxer
I'm not a UFC fighter I'm not Sean
Strickland or one of these guys all
right by the way now that guy he is not
a guy you want to get into a street he's
C he's yeah he's had a crazy childhood
and that comes out in his fist the
best thing is when he told his opponent
he says look you can say whatever you
want if you talk about my dad one more
time in Canada I will kill you I will go
to jail and I'll be okay with period and
then the guy's like you know what let's
just find just have a ke& P you showed
the other funny that's F Michael let's
let's talk about let's talk about
politics okay so 2017 2017 yes uh you're
making that video right politically how
much have you changed in the last seven
years I think I've learned a lot more so
I don't think I've changed I think I've
learned more about I not I think I know
I have you know honestly I didn't
care speak or
pay much attention to politics up
until the
Republican convention the Republican
debates and then the debate with Hillary
and Trump um to be totally honest with
you so since that time I've learned a
lot and um you know I have a I think a
clear point of view on the game I have a
clear point of view on politicians I
have a clear point of view
on where I stand you know as you get
older you know your money uh becomes
more important to you your taxes become
more important to you um and I think for
me learning and going through and
understanding first initially politics
through social media and then politics
in real life and educating myself I have
I have my point of view on things have
changed um you know I'll just jump right
to it cuz I know you want to get to it
you know my my point of view on
Trump you know and I want to ask you
this cuz because I know you're sort of
you consider yourself right now a trump
guy I'm a center right guy but but but
right now oh there's no question about
it so the thing is for me like you
handle yourself in such a classy way and
people are like you know Pat you should
run for president Pat you'd be a great
president and you know you've
accomplished and you're so successful
and you know the way everybody you know
in your office you know sort of presents
himself and it's a classy place and it's
you know from the head down I would
imagine the the thing about Trump
that's the hardest amongst other things
the hardest for me and a lot of people
to get past along with the list but the
top the the is the way he conducts
himself as a president and some people
say well Mike rap you talk M I'm
not the president of the United States
totally and the insulting people the I
don't know thing about
um um McCain I don't know anything about
his politics but I know he served this
country and he was uh went through what
he went through for somebody like Trump
who is a draft
Dodger somebody like Trump to insult him
and give him a nickname and say he
prefers his war heroes not to be
captured to me is the antithesis and
that's a big word I'm using it just cuz
I'm here with with you Pat that's a big
word for me that's the antithesis of
anything
presidential and uh uh I'm a talker
uh uh and all that stuff but the
nicknames and the disrespect for the
fact that you're the president Time and
Time and Time and Time and Time After
again to me is the thing that's hardest
for me to get by because it's
representative of everything in this
country he's the representative of us in
the country I know also his bark is
bigger than his bite but being the
president that's a Extremely Loud bark
his bark is bigger than his bite I think
he says a lot more than he does I think
his policies uh uh weren't a lot of his
policies that he did while he was in
office I I I like uh I think he did do
things that were good for the country
but the the the the the spillage the
messiness the the the the the
antagonistic Behavior the antagonistic
Behavior towards anybody anybody whether
they worked with him or not but the
people that worked with him once uh uh
uh he feels betrayed once he feels
insulted to just attack attack attack
insult uh in the in the in the most
disrespectful uh embarrassing way uh is
just to me is is not acceptable as a
president to me and so so so then that
means you're a Biden guy that do no
that doesn't mean anything so then would
you still vote for him would you still
vote for Trump no well I didn't vote for
Trump you mean would I still vote for
Biden 2024 would you vote for Trump this
year would you consider it yeah well I
said the other
day that vot voting for Donald Trump is
on the table I mean that I saw and by
the way 50 cents set that with the whole
$53 million credit card New York mayor
Adams what they're doing the all the
immigrants but let me let me he on the
table Big Mike everybody's saying
everybody's changing let me you think
Killer Mike or k m so let me let me kind
of give you you you I want to hear your
yeah perfect let's talk about that let's
talk about specifically with that so for
me I said voting for pig dick Donald
Trump yeah I know you did I I know you
did that's and I love that when they put
it up there they they refer to him in
the the nickname I gave gave what tell
me about the is this after watching a
Jimmy Jimmy K deal or is that just your
nickname I created that nickname I
patent it and maybe you could help me
check the
patent Pig dick Donald Trump dick stain
Donald Trump I have the patent on that
so if you use it unfortunately I will
have to sue you I understand I respect
what was the inspiration for the pig
dick you know sometimes stroke of Genius
yeah a stroke nice one a stroke of
Genius just comes what do you stroke
comes down it's just a lot of double
andr there's no there's nothing specific
to it you're just kind of it's it's a
name you gave with no meaning behind it
do you think like like do you say like
dror
J Air Jordan yeah yeah the Mamba yeah
Pig Donald Trump It just fits Patrick it
fits here's what's funny about it you
know it fits and I see in your face
because I know you have a good sense of
humor you can't even make eye contct on
you know it f are you kidding me I'm all
about sense of humor I love I love being
entertained and I I love the funny
stories but it's funny you're saying
that but you're saying you're still open
to the idea so let me give you my I know
let me give you my rebutt on those
things please do so for me having been
I'm 45 years old okay having been in
business for you know 20 some years and
working with different
personalities what what I valued when I
was first recruiting in
242 is very different when I was 30
after I wasted my time with a lot of
people then what I valued at 3540 and
then today right today is a complete
different story then here's the other
part that I learned I learned recruiting
A salesperson yesterday one of the
client CEOs I'm Consulting for asked me
a question on what kind of salespeople
should I recruit I said look it depends
on what product you're selling meaning
if you're selling a $100 product you
can't bring a guy that's suited up
because you're can to intimidate the
customer that's buying a $100 product
it's not a big product but if you're
selling a product that's a million dooll
product it's a different language versus
if you're selling a $20 million house in
Miami or Coral Gables or Palm Beach it's
a different salesperson the same
salesperson can fail selling this
product but succeed selling this product
ideally in a perfect world you would say
I want somebody was this I want somebody
who was eloquent I want somebody who
talks like this and all these things
many times you would get a new guy that
comes in with a phenomenal resume looks
good everything looks good then put him
in the ring have him get to work guess
what nothing gets down right back in the
days there was a book I read called the
Lincoln on leadership by Donald T
Phillips Rob if you want to pull it up I
think lot 13 in this book he talks about
just type in search until you find your
Grant okay search until you find your
Grant I don't think I've told the story
on the Pod search until you find your
Grant in this book right there the last
chapter he I think it's chapter 13 He
says search until you find your grand
which one is it R 11 or 13 it's one of
the two go up one go up one keep
searching keep search it until you find
your Grant okay so he tells the story
the war is going on North and South all
these things are going on he hires this
guy who's the most trained person in the
military he promotes him to go and win
the war his name is mlan okay he brings
him in and he says this is our guy you
know what mlen does all day long with
his soldiers keeps training them
training them training them every day
report to Lincoln report to Lincoln
report to Lincoln he brings after 10
layers of generals he changed nobody had
the balls to go to war except for one
guy he finally finds this guy named
ulyses es Grant he comes in and he says
hey we got to go win the war he says say
no more this guy's a drunk he's an
alcoholic he's a mess he drinks late at
night at bars an absolute crazy man he
can never get a hold of him Lincoln was
always pissed off cuz Grant would never
call him but guess what ended up
happening he won the war do you really
give a if the guy that won the war
as an alcoholic no you don't so that's
the argument in that now somebody could
say in today's world you know who ysus
esram would have been oh my God look at
this irresponsible this this that no no
you won the war you're safe be quiet go
home and send him a thank you letter
instead of all this trashing that you're
doing with him and FYI he becomes a
two-term president afterwards after uh
uh Trump so let's go through some of
your list draft Dodger at this point
that was a big point in the 80s to say
that no one gives a today everybody
running today is a draft Dodger okay so
that quality on talking to the
other side it's irrelevant today it's a
good one for ' 80s not for 2024 but but
you served right I served McCain served
I'm a guy that I want the guy servant
but it's a different era today but but
I'm just saying in terms
of you as somebody who served just
specifically that I know that had to be
like you're like what is that for sure
it's it's for by the way for sure with
the fact that not even serving is a
bigger issue for me not the draft
dodging stuff the draft dodging stuff
you got to Rich that what what are you
going to do for your kid maybe it's
going to be a different situation you're
not going to know it if you're dad's got
money and maybe you're going to be like
what am I doing going over here and the
dad gets you to get out those are some
of the benefits that comes with the last
name what do you your son your kids are
going to have a different way they use
the last name than you did right because
you built the last name right so Trump
didn't build the last name Fred build
the last name there was a lot of
benefits to the last name but and then
obviously Trump takes it to the next
level and then the McCain thing McCain
let's go to the McCain so McCain I don't
like that comment I just tell you
straight up I don't like that comment
why even say that you don't have to say
that why would you say that he served
put his life you know on the line prison
of War he went whether there's
credibility behind it or he marketed it
or whatever it's not something that I
sit there and say yeah I'm totally with
him I'm not that guy I actually wasn't
for that and I openly talked about you
don't have to say that so you L at New
York for the longest time in us they
used to talk about the fact that America
can't handle a New York president
because you're New York look how loud
you are he's New York you know what
feedback Tom gave to him two days ago we
don't always have to be loud Tom's not
from New York he made a note today Mike
he's like you be calm you tell what the
you mean Tom is from Tom is a very
different light but guess what York is
loud tough competitive calling out so
America Got a New York president cuz
that's who they wanted and then what's
the last one that you said bigger than
bite here's what I will tell you what
did I say what B is bigger his bark is
bigger than his bite so the thing with
Trump to when I was with uh Bill Maher
and I'm asking this question and this
whole idea oh my God this guy's going to
get elected let me tell you what he's
going to be doing if he gets elected EXC
me World War III do you want that man to
have access to the you know the nuclear
button and and all this other stuff bro
you talk re re you talking about just
with Bill Mah yeah I was I was with Bill
Mah last week and and we're having this
conversation and I said in 2016 all the
left ever said is the fact that this
guy's going to start a nuclear war
that's what he's going to do guess what
happened he goes there is no war Isis
disappears the last time you said Isis
was under Obama we haven't said Isis for
a while so economy is doing great
everything's great then we have Co 2 and
a half years later then they blame it
all on him he operation warp speed
Camala Harris and those guys said they
would never take the vaccine while Trump
was coming out with it but guess what
those uh pharmaceutical companies did
you know when the vaccine comes out two
days after the election so if it would
have come out before Trump probably
would have had a chance of winning but
it comes out two days after why you
don't think somebody behind closed doors
said come out two days after the
election 100% 100% they did so the
gamesmanship of how much they hated this
guy because he's a talker he talks
so much it's constant but that's
him that's his profile you are not going
to change him you're 53 you said you're
going to be 54 in March right so March
20 you're going to be 54 okay so how
much do you think somebody can change
you today at this phase of your life
with your personality shifts okay you
could bend a little bit subtle bro and
that's not going to be that dramatic
right it's going to be subtle if
somebody was going to do anything to us
maybe at 11: maybe 15 maybe 18 no one's
going to change Trump so all of those
things of
people that used to ask and said if only
he could be like this let me just
simplified for you he's not going to
absolutely not period but if you like no
war if you like a great economy if you
like unemployment that was low for
African-Americans they're making more
money than ever before if you want data
and all that stuff was good then great
go this side if you want a messy world
that we have right now Russia Ukraine
where we're giv another they're calling
it a border bill out of $118 billion 60
billion to Ukraine don't call it a
border Bill he would have actually
address those things that's simple it is
for me but by the way never spoken to
him I've never met him I've never broke
bread I don't have I've never I've seen
him speak but we've never had
interaction for there to be a loyalty
there is no relationship loyalty it's
policy loyalty one one thing that I
really
disdain in the mainstream Media or even
even media in general e even even with
you guys or or or when people are
talking politics is if the other side or
a president you don't like does
something good it's it's never
acknowledged so I'm going to ask you
this because you could probably answered
this better than me what has the Biden
Administration done that you do like
first of all the the economy is doing
good it's okay who is it good for though
it's good for the rich guy the people
that are making money they're doing good
that's you yeah I mean I'm I'm okay I'm
not again like I said to Bill Maher uh
guys like me are going to be good no
matter who's the president by the way
the more they print money I'm always
going to make more money because money
always rolls up to the wealthy because
the poor and middle income don't know
how to keep it they know how to spend it
the more they spend it who do they spend
it on on capitalist that own equity and
the equity people make money if I would
say you know the fact that the the
expectation of a massive recession to be
taking place well that didn't happen
because that could have been in shambles
right unemployment stayed okay I think
Powell uh the way he managed the
interest rates while the way we were
going about the economy was okay um
interest rates are they're not good
right now it it should stay like and by
the way I said this last week they suck
now cuz I just bought a house and a car
in the last and it the interest rates
are like where did you buy your house I
I don't want to say you're not going to
like this but not not in this state and
not in not in Texas so I didn't get the
uh you know okay New York or California
something like that I will say this to
you on the interest rates even when
Trump gets elected my concern is he
fires Powell and he brings somebody to
lower the rates if he lower the rates
immediately we're going back to fake
success again and we need to filter out
a little bit of the fake success there's
way too many people that made fake money
that need to just quit so here's kind of
what happens guy goes and starts a
business he should have never started a
business he's a better guy working for a
business owner because he doesn't have
good habits because of his bad habits he
hurts the employees he should get out of
business and go work for the other guy
that is a good operator during fake
success time these people look like
great operators but during economy like
this they get exposed and then they go
and say Hey man can I work with you no
problem come on down because we we need
more solid operators not fake success
operators we had a lot of those fake Su
success operators during that 128 Monon
economic expansion of pretty much zero
interest rat so yeah I'm not I'm not
prediction go ahead prise for impact
you're GNA vote for Trump and I'll tell
you
why uh because you're I don't know if I
could do that I'll tell you why hang on
tell and by the way you're talking to
somebody that was probably closer to
your camp in
2016 this guy hated like I never said
hate I didn't like Trump but also also
I've never said the word hate you can
roll the tape uh I didn't like a lot of
the things he did a lot of the things
you highlighted for me there was the the
one that like I was like I can't do this
was when he pretended like he didn't
know who David Duke was everyone know
David Duke leader of the KKK is out
there in Louisiana okay come on Trump
you don't know who this guy
is but you're also a reasonable person
and you're also a dude like you're a
dude you like to play ball you like
hip-hop like to talk you're not a
woke LGBT unicorn type kid that's not
you that's not you no so you've seen
what the left has produced over the last
four years again I'm telling you
somebody that's been in that camp I'm a
JFK Democrat why am I a JFK Democrat cuz
my dad was a JFK Democrat so that
basically led to me like oh JFK is the
man he's a Democrat that led to me
liking Clinton I like Clinton all right
cool you know he's out there kissing
babies you know getting like
that Charming guy Charming we met him
recently start of a guy
his wife that's a whole another
conversation but you know if if if you
were looking at politics and you said
you weren't paying attention to it I my
senior year I worked at the in
Tallahassee in Florida State where I
went to school I was uh worked at the uh
Capitol building this was during the
2000 election Gore versus Bush I was a
Clinton guy I was rooting for Gore what
happen you I used to see Jeff Bush
George W I used to see I was around this
oh we saw what happened during the
Bush Administration the book ends of it
uh 911 and then the the great financial
meltdown there was no B way in a million
years that old John McCain was going to
win the election over cool Barack Obama
wasn't happening y so if you if you if
you believed in the Obama Doctrine all
right you know be nice to each other
whatever there's no way you were voting
for for trump it just wasn't in the
cards it wasn't happening he was
abrasive he was racist the media y y y
and he was a joke like New Yorkers like
it was like he's a ball bu and Troll
he's a he's AIT but here's why I think
you're going to vote for him this time
cuz you've seen what happened under his
first term you didn't like it he's the
you know he's the pig dick and he's got
the Mean Tweets and he's orange but life
was good there was no Wars the economy
was going good but damn he's he's
annoying to look at but you also can
acknowledge that the media had a major
role in that a major role that when you
take a step back yes you also
acknowledge that because acknowled that
you know that one thing about the
Charlottesville that that that I ranted
about yes and I was wrong about the both
sides thing yeah yeah and but I so
irresponsible and I respect the out
let me let me hear him out hang on go a
little bit more what do you mean by that
you were wrong on that no because he
said the both side you know there's good
people on both sides and when you see
the full quote Yeah Yeah that wasn't
what what he said and and
and you know I I ranted on him hard for
that hard there's some video about it
whatever I mean I ranted hard cuz I was
like what are you talking about man
course cuzz you got played and here's
what the re this is why I think you're
going to vote for Trump is cuz you much
like me much like many of people
independent thinkers not the Sheep
realize we kind of got played a little
bit yes Trump ain't exactly the
smoothest character he's not he's not
Jesus Christ no but he actually his
policies and who he has around him are
way better than what's going on there
and here's my final point you see what's
going on with the Border you see what's
going on with the wokeness you see
what's going on with culture wars and
you see what's going on with actual Wars
yeah specifically you see who the the
Democrats have expose their hand
especially the progressive left you see
what's going on between Israel and Gaza
you have three starve David Ka on your
chest right now and someone who is a
proud New Yorker your whole life you see
what the Democratic party has turned
into this de SG woke manifestation of
ridiculousness intersectionality
decolonialization you're looking at that
and you say you know what as much as I
can't stand big dick Donald Trump you
said it at least he's normal at
least doesn't want to turn my boy into a
girl well at least he's normal yes you
at least it's Pol at least he doesn't
want to turn my boy into a girl at least
he's defending Israel not the
terrorists and at the end of the day I'm
a reasonable person yeah so like you
said initially I think I'm going to
consider this oh it's I'm considering it
but to pull that I don't know we don't
pull levers anymore actually pull that
lever pulling the lever for Biden and
and then I'm gonna tell you right now I
won't vote I'm not voting for Biden I'm
not voting for kamla I'm not you know
but then you can't talk and you
need to be able to talk but wait a
minute wait a minute so so you're saying
so for you I won't vote for them so no
matter what that decision is happening
no I'm not that's not happening who
what I'm not or anybody well but Mikey
what about anybody elsea about anybody
he's saying is there's nobody I'm saying
what if knew Sumer one of these cats pop
up Gavin I just left California I'm not
voting for Gavin with the good hair I
love that I love that Gavin with a good
hair just like be out of here so
sobody here my thing though so I'm not a
sucker they love him you see how much
they love him though his they like his
hair but go deeper why do you say you're
not a sucker what does that mean cuz I
lived I just moved out of Los Angeles
okay I'm it's not happening man explain
that for those of the people that have
never lived in La why the hell you've
been there for 20 plus years why the
hell did you move out well I moved out
because I wanted to go to New York I
didn't move out for any reason I wanted
to move back to New York full-time
that's why I
left but the just on on top the the the
the the homelessness in New York in
sorry in Los Angeles and in California
San Diego San Francisco I could speak on
those those places Sacramento is so but
particularly in Los Angeles in C in in
in the Los Angeles area is is is is
unacceptable it's it's scary it's um I
don't know the the the how to fix it
it's it's it's unacceptable it's um not
safe it's not sanitary um I know
California and Los Angeles is a driving
City but I do like to walk when you walk
you shouldn't feel uh uh um just
uncomfortable by hordes and hordes and
hordes of homeless people it's not good
for them it ain't good for me it ain't
good for it's not good across the board
and the taxes suck uh but the
homelessness and and how it went you
know down so bad so quickly um and the
crime all let's not forget about the
crime let's not forget about the crime
so so Mike you said cuz I I saw the
video too Pat played it the other day
about you said you know still voting for
him it's still on the table uh we saw
Adam mentioned what was the break what
was that moment Mike was it the way that
the administration treated the Palestine
Gaza the terror the hostages because
Mike real talk let's be honest if Trump
was first of all none of that was
happening at all when Trump was in
everybody just know you know this
was shaking people's arms
ripping him off the socket I I think two
things a it wouldn't have happened if it
was under him and number two Mike let's
be real if well nobody did it in those
four years here's my here's my thing
though if it did happen under Trump and
there was hostages Jewish you don't
think that guy would have gone in the
next day special forces and just shot
and killed every Trump would not play
this was it was it this thing Mike
that made you go Israel Israel pushed me
over the top what was it Mike like
please please get into it the the the
the the good cop bad cop between K
and Joe Biden Joe at first you know what
he said it you know it it it was good at
first what he said but you know I don't
remember exactly what he said but but it
was good Nei does here and and Israeli
and it resonated with Israelis but the
good cop bad cop between him and kamla
regarding this was not cool and and it's
offensive you know that they are doing
that uh uh speaking that way uh when
such such a horrible
unacceptable situation took place in
Israel and and and that's when that's
when I first said that I don't know what
the date was I I believe it was sometime
in October when I first said that and
and and that's and since then I was like
I'm just I can't do it I can't do it I
cannot vote for them I you know the
Border stuff um it shouldn't be harder
for me to fly back into the United
States from Toronto two three hours uh
and I'm famous I played a a de agent on
a show called Prison Break de agent
border range they know me it shouldn't
take me big star that I am
pbd to get from Toronto flying to New
York it shouldn't take me three hours to
fly back on that trip uh and take you
five minutes across the border it
shouldn't be harder for me to get back
into my country from Toronto than it is
to cross the border and it is and it
ain't cool and then you know the thing
that pushed me over the top this week
listen I live in New York you know I
want to be clear point that M that's
that's amazing that's CRA CLI that put
that on
the boom I am Rapp part but but but Pat
you know I'm going to just say this you
know the media also does this it
portrays New York as this
there's not as much homeless that I see
you I'm not Mr Patrol I'm not in the
five bur scour ing there's not as much
homeless specifically in Manhattan um
you know I don't know the crime
statistics you know it's it's still New
York it's still the greatest City on the
on the planet in my opinion it's still
everything um you know uh that being
said when I
saw the cops in Time Square One of the
epicenters of New York one of the
epicenters of all things American in the
in in in the world you think of the
United States that's one of the places
they dro the ball uh Dick Clark the late
Dr late great Dick Clark you dro the
ball in Time Square when NYPD Blue when
nypd's finest could get
jumped by migrants illegal migrants
illegal migrants in my city I'm not the
owner but I'm born and raised in
Manhattan when NYPD can get jumped by
illegal migrants in New York C City and
then walk out with no bail raising their
middle fingers like Tupac did when he
came out of the Court unbelievable
you that this in in New York
City that and I know that's a city thing
I know it's nothing to do with the
presid but that
is we have that's when I go is New York
still the greatest city in the world if
if you can do that cuz that is a slap in
the face to everything uh uh that is
great special about New York and that is
a slap in the face that is everything
that's great special about the United
States of America yep and and that's
when I said the other day this is just I
can't and hom is wearing a freaking Kobe
jersey a 24 L that's New York and that's
when I'm like this is where I I know the
best I I know New York City more better
than anything any other place that I
I've spent a lot of time in California
that is my city that's just the most
blatant disrespectful that you
could do that you can do this in New
York City you could beat let me tell you
something to to think that you could put
your hands on a cop in any City let
alone in a city that you ain't from in a
country that you ain't from when I'm
when I haven't traveled the world a lot
but when I'm in Israel Argentina the
places that I've been to I I I I find
out the rules and regulations and I'm a
disruptive personality if you can't spit
you don't spit when you're in Thailand
you you can't say certain things it'll
get in trouble let alone put your hands
on a cop the audacity to put to jump a a
New York city cop and walk out
with no bail that shit's embarrassing am
I am I these are the and Iz we talked
about this like CLI that too yeah these
are the these are the same imagine
traveling to a different country can
beating up a cop anywhere else no we're
ready for this even in your own country
Britney grinder did a year and a half in
jail bringing some weed to Russia it
wasn't even it wasn't a it wasn't a vape
thing but my and you could do this and
you walk out with no bail fing double
birdie besides the flipping off hold on
getting stom out stomped out my this
what po me off other New Yorkers didn't
do number two number three this is
the same NYPD that were Heroes that were
running into the World Trade I did this
Mike last week running into the World
Trade saving people and nobody's helping
these dudes and then you know what that
means the system they went into court
and they were like bye get out and go
back in the street that's that really
hurt my heart as as I'm born in New York
Hospital that hurt my heart so
here's a question for you sorry to curs
no it's all good so do do you speak to I
know you keep it clean here no I try to
but every once in a while Vinnie and
Adam they they sponsor the the so so we
going back to it so do you speak not I'm
not looking for names are there other
people who would have never thought
about voting for Trump celebrities who
are either in sports or business or
whatever Hollywood do they call and say
Michael what the hell is going on in New
York Pat I can't I can't speak on other
celebrities no I'm not saying names but
I can't even say other names I can't
even say other names I I but I could say
this
there's a lot of people in the Jewish
Community uh uh that I've spoken to a
lot that are like I never ever ever
thought you know some celebrities yeah
some celebrities yeah some celebrities
uh uh that I never thought I'd be at
that point also ever and they're like
they were hard body like me like f Trump
you know and all that stuff like never
trumpers that's what you call them a lot
of people I would say in my world and I
could say you know two celebrities that
pop in my mind that said I I never would
have thought I would have even
considered and here I am yeah that's
exactly what's that's the reason that I
said I'm I think you're going to vote
for Trump and it's not even necessarily
you it could be any extension of you any
reasonable person especially Jewish is
going to look back and be like the Jews
are not voting the the the the con how
about the Congressional testimony uh
with the University of presidents could
have not condemn har wait Harvard
Harvard and all all the CL G going they
were literally protesting like
supporting Hamas and I think that
exposed like the Jewish Community was
like what by the way here I thought of
substitute any group any group other
than Jews we want to genocide all
Mexicans all gays All Blacks all Asians
they would have been condemnation to the
highest degree but Jew somehow it's
acceptable you know what why is it
acceptable M you know why because we are
the last acceptable group to public
hate you you can't do it uh uh against
lgbtq you get cancelled by uh uh black
community Asian Community disabled
Community you can't say the RW you you
little person you can't say the MW
there's there's a lot of things that
where you if you say them if I said it
right now yo you're
done but you can
openly
hate Jews we are the last acceptable uh
uh uh group Community religion a race
where it's where it's it's it's it's
it's it's not only uh acceptable uh uh
it's it's sort of no consequences no con
it's you're emboldened to do it right
now particularly right now that being
said I will say anti-Semitism
anti-jewish has been around forever it's
going to continue to go around but it
is
[Music]
extremely
it's it's it's it's it's extremely um
disheartening and and and um concerning
and
infuriating what's the the not you know
what's happened in in to the real people
the victims is one thing but but the
claudian gays the MIT woman who somehow
still has a job the Harvard woman the
people thinking that they could say uh
get off my camp Zionist who can tell my
friend in a in a cafe in New Orleans I'm
not going to serve you cuz you're
Zionist all the all the that we've
seen whether it's Zionist anti-jewish
all that stuff that is is is a surprise
and it's it's up Rob what's this
year Michael raing J TB Omar AOC you're
in government so so this is a which
story is this Rob this is our oober
regarding uh yeah the squad right there
and their support for Palestine in our
government literally and this is the a
further more proof of why I don't think
you can vote for the Democratic party
I'm not I'm not doing it I'm telling you
I'm not doing it I ain't doing it I'm
not with them i' I've been off of them
the the alc and I mean I could I got a
question for you guys I got a question
specifically for the two of you you you
and Michael and everybody's like
rapaport's been red pilled and I do I
take two red pills in the morning two
red pills in the night it's working for
what you know the red pills you know
they have been red pills so let me ask
you you know how in
1960 the whole Berry gold water where it
used to be only you know 64% of
African-Americans would vote Democrat by
1964 that 64% goes to 92% of blacks vote
for Democrat because Democrats were
brilliant in the way to pin Republicans
as racist against blacks and it lasted
like that for decades till today 60
years it's lasted like that till today
do you think this is going to be the
October 7th event's going to be the type
of an event where uh where right there
exactly 1964 92% voted for Democrat look
what it's been it's been anywhere
between 84 to 92% voting for democ
they've owned the Democrats have owned
the black vote for decades they've owned
it for decades right question for you do
you think the October 7th event and the
way they've handled it will it be in a
way way
where there may be a massive Exodus from
Jews leaving the Democratic party or no
you think it's still going to be the
same I do I think that you think massive
like a 10 plus percentage I think way
more than that because I'll tell you why
um I've had plenty of conversations with
guys like Michael raport Jewish guys
reasonable dudes make their money do
their thing good people good family guys
and I say what's up you voting and I
know these guys good friends you're
Jewish yeah and I um I said could you
vote you gonna vote for Biden you gonna
vote for Trump now what are they going
to do how many times I've had this
conversation they're like I I don't
think I can do this thing I didn't re
here's the biggest thing we knew on the
far right we knew the the Jews will not
replace us Tiki tortured C cacus wearing
Pig dick gloving those guys we knew
about those guys and the Jews are just
like yeah anything with the KKK with the
neo-nazis we ain't with that but we had
no clue it's what was permeating on the
left and it's the difference between the
left and the right is that it's in
government on the left the squad is the
squ in government yeah when the
Democratic party when when they have
votes to basically censure Rashida Talib
for basically supporting Palestine zero
Republicans are with that they're all
like yeah we're out on this lady
majority of the democratic party they're
like yeah we're we're with her we're
cool so from an infrastructure from a
systemic problem in in government in
Congress you just as a Jew you can't you
can't look at this and say yeah I'm I'm
with this because if you if you are that
means you're just turning a blind eye to
everything that's happening a and you
have to just like the blacks basically
were like yo we can't get with the berry
Goldwater thing civil rights everything
that changed in the early 1960s changed
the black vote this is going to change
the Jewish vote so you're saying it's
going to be that big I do but listen you
know 133% of this country is black 1% of
this country is Jewish it's not a big
it's not a big number but they have a
big voice they have a they have a
massive voice so a flip a a it's kind of
like saying I got a thousand people here
in a room who are not on social media
but I got a thousand people here about
to hear me speak and then a guy on the
other side says yeah I got a YouTube
channel with 28 million subscribers I'm
willing to have you on the podcast you
got a thousand physical people that
guy's one person with the kind of
influence to you know sky so for me if
if if this does
happen if it's a 10 plus perc shift yeah
I believe so that's more that's not a
10% plus shift because the influence
they have yes that's going to be
astronomical shift look when we when we
see the when we see the genocide Joe
campaign on the left from the Hamas
Brigade when we see this and they're
just like we can't support Joe Biden
anyone anyone with normal uh
sensibilities is going to be like okay
cool
just help elect Donald Trump that moved
the capital to Jerusalem okay that will
basically squash Hamas so go ahead keep
campaigning for genocide Joe the
Democratic party is your only chance
left Hamas crew to basically you agree
do you agree with him on it's going to
be it's going to be a double digit shift
on the Jewish vote I I agree with him
yes I I I I I agree with him I mean
listen it's November when this is
happening right now we're February a lot
of a lot of different things can happen
but I I if it was today next month I
would say 100% but we've also been
fooled by the Trump trump is a Hitler
he's loves Nazis it's like his daughter
his daughter married an Orthodox Jewish
guy called Jared Kushner his Grand his
Grand children are Jewish this guy grew
up in New York City in Staten Island I
believe it's Queens is where he's from
he's been around Jews his whole life the
fact that people think that Donald Trump
is Hitler so be they would say that but
and I I hate to be that guy but I kind
of don't we told everybody so I didn't
fall into the personality because I
looked past all that and I'm not special
I didn't go to college how did how did I
know sh yeah thanks Mike but think about
this think about it the black black v
Killer Mike all these people everybody's
shifting right Ice Cube everybody's
going Trump the Jewish vote as you guys
are saying as Jewish guys it's a WAP
right how are they going to they know
that they're losing you know how they're
going to keep on to it the 22 million
Michael that are coming in here
illegally those people are going to vote
that's their only can't vote Yes they
can't how many states Rob how many
states can vote with no ID no no picture
on the ID what do you mean you have to
be registered no but I thought that was
part of the deal how the hell do they
register what do what do you mean how do
they register and in what state are they
going to register we all know that
California is going blue we already know
that Adam they're going to flip Texas I
rob you have that video that I sent you
about the voters was Clos last time yeah
I sent rob a slack today Rob I sent rob
a slack about there's a guy in Texas
Michael going up to all these migrants
and interview them ask asking them who
they're going to vote for uh where is it
is this
it no that's not it that's that's that's
an illegal that killed somebody and the
hit just keep on coming go up is that
it that's it right here he's just going
up to migrants P up the 20 this is the
votes ready they're
illegals helping
us of course you are
of
course he's a very
good yeah's a different thing it's
V I don't know what kind of policy but
any that just crossed the
border barely speaks English has no clue
what the hell's going on in America
should not be able to vote but Adam but
but guess what the plan's working though
but hold on what do you guys think oh
yeah here voter identification laws in
effect a strict photo ID is the dark
blue look at that and then no document
required to vote is gray Adam look at
that and then ID required no photo guess
what this is shady ass business and this
is exactly the reason the border is wide
open and if you still are out there
thinking it's a humanitarian and there
there's kids in cages you're stupid cuz
that that is the answer right there
because they know they're losing the
black vote they lost the Jewish vote
they're losing everybody I've never
understood the no ID thing dude I need
to go ID to go into a bar I need to go
ID to buy some liquor I need to go buy
ID to buy some ettes I need an ID to go
anywhere I want to get you need an ID to
get on a plane here to orando in order
to vote is crazy no ID needed explain
that to me way because IDs are racist
apparently it is it is it is strategic
though an FYI your numbers wise you need
how many electoral 277 Chris's working
on it do you know on the states how many
states require no idea I think it's like
13 or 14 of the 22 states that doesn't
require uh uh n ID I think 227 of the
Electoral are of those States isn't that
weird did you did you did you get the
numbers it's the majority that's right
the 227 are from states that don't
require documentation oh so we're
screwed let me tell you something
Republicans should be thinking their
lucky stars or something called The
Electoral College because if it was a
popular vote you guys would get
smokedet single time be thankful for the
Electoral well thank God but I am happy
that cu going the front bro like I I
don't know what video your your uh your
wife's mom or whatever said and I was
just like any all of that negative Trump
cuz and I had to step back and realize
that people were sold on it so much
because everything told you CNN MSN the
the news he's evil he's this he would do
this it's actually refreshing to see
somebody go holy the the grass was
cut and now I can see the snakes cuz
they're right in front of your face and
once it hits how many how many rap ports
are out there I think a lot I think it's
growing no no mean meaning not you Mike
he's saying that are waking up to this
oh I think it's it's a growing what I
mean is to me these guys are these guys
are very similar because I remember
first time I talked to him first time I
talked to Adam he's like hey you know
what if I come join the team value tamon
and you know I'm at a face of my life
and he's in Florida at the time and I'm
in Dallas Addison so I came here because
we were shooting a video an ad video for
one of our events which we never ended
up using a footage cuz it was using it
on a helicopter and and was at the same
time so I'm like I'm not going to get
footage and then I talked to him I said
so tell me politically where you at so
you know you I'm like you know
independent and so how do you feel about
Trump he's like well you know well kind
of this and we just kind of it was
almost as if like you know and I'm like
okay cool sounds good and then you come
you talk you kind of go through the
process I paid him $1,000 when Biden won
on a bet I know him $1,000 okay a lot of
people did yeah and uh uh uh the point
and then I go from there to here how
many people are sitting down saying I
have buyers remorse I want my vote back
or sitting there saying I can't do this
again for another four years and I think
what I've realized also and this is
something that you're going to have to
deal with as well is that dude you're
never going to love the person like if
you're voting based on the personality
we would all vote for Justin Trudeau
he's nice he's goodlook
we'd all vote for Gavin cuz he's got
great hair but policies and personality
are totally different I think Donald
Trump's personality is Nails on a
chalkboard I I he speaks you know kamla
Harris that dirty like when he
speaks it's so inappropriate it like the
the stuff the McCain stuff I'm
right there with you but if you can look
past the personality and look at the
policies that's what it matters for you
look at Joe Biden I dude people hate on
Joe Biden I'm like he's just like an old
scile nice guy he's not some cruel evil
dictator like I don't get the hate I get
that he's old and he's the crepid and
you called him a a kadav Joe a cadav Joe
nice another stroke another good one I
mean that's Lord but when you look at
the policies and the open border and the
taxes and the
lgbtqs Dei driven ESG Doctrine it's just
hard to just be like I want more of that
baby so I'm a like i' and I've had to
learn Michael Michael rport this was not
me I was just like ah I can't deal with
Trump him but no you have to look
at things and be like yeah as much as he
is Nails trying to chop you have to go
policy I think I think you're GNA you're
going to decide for yourself privately
when you're when you're by yourself
nobody is around and you'll you'll
evaluate what's most important policy
for you and then you'll you'll adjust
accordingly we still got a long ways to
go you said it right you we're we're
February right now the game hasn't even
started this is like the pregame how
ugly you think it's going to get the
next few months bad Define bad in
regards to Trump
Biden I think I me it's it's going to be
bad I I think it would be to be to be
totally honest I think it'd be
worse if Trump ran and doesn't win I
think shit's going to get people are
going to go nuts nuts nuts nuts cuz I
think his his Core group of
uh uh uh supporters are more prone to I
think the the the Biden people are more
screaming yelling crying but the other
people are more like yo we're going to
take over the you know that that
kind of mentality so I I I don't want
any of that you know nor does anybody
but that that I think you know would be
a concern if if if he lost uh even fair
and square what evidence do you have
that his people might get upset and do
something about it I can't think of
anything that they've ever done
something about well Dr J wore number
six it was a month that was before this
month I don't I can't think of anything
that they've ever done that when they
get upset yeah so but yeah I mean it's
going to be it's going to be wild so
Nikki Haley do you curious to know what
you think about this so do you think
it'll ever get to a time where one of
the states will uh um you know separate
and become its own country in America
you think you think that's going to
happen in our lifetime no tell me
why because it's just not it's not a
feasible thing that one of the no is
that what she's talking about like Texas
no she's saying it's not possible but
there's discussion about the fact that
Texas is so sick and tired of the fact
that they're trying to protect the
border and Biden's Administration is
getting involved so for some states to
say look we're going to do it ourselves
we don't need you anymore that's not
going to happen that's just it's just
you know the founding fathers it's just
it's just not going to happen it's just
it's just not it's just can't H Texas
it's it's the most American state
it's not going to happen I don't think
it's going to happen you think that
would could actually happen pbd I I I
don't know if I think it's going to
happen or not I think I think Texas is
most American but Texas is saying you
guys are no longer American you're
France I think Texas is saying
California is France the other way
around Texas is saying we're following
the founders you're not you know we're
we're being American you're being
European I hear you this still doesn't
mean they're going to be their own
country it's just not going to happen
but okay but you said it's going to get
very ugly yes do you think it's going to
get ugly to the point where you you know
Trump's Camp is going to come out and
say you want to do this no problem we're
going to flip six states and here's what
we're going to turn it into that's going
to be its own country like you don't
think it's going to get that ugly ugly
ugly cuz j6 wasn't ugly j6 a lot can say
was ugly but not not as ugly as what
you're talking about you're talking
about Civil War I'm talking purely to
the point where because I'm thinking
that's where you're going if you're
saying it's going to get ugly that means
one side is saying screw you you let 20
million people in we will never be able
to win again this will be a Democrat
vote for the next 20 30 40 years you're
going to turn this into Europe we're
going to be losing our voices and I'm
not having this I'm I'm not going to
live in a in a country God forbid that
that happens uh you know that's crazy if
it if it something like that happens and
it's like that kind of thing I mean you
know as I've gotten older you know
anything is is is possible you know
there's been a lot of things that have
happened you know in my adult life that
you never thought that the towers would
come down uh uh uh you know you you
there's a lot of things that I never
thought would happened uh uh God forbid
that happens uh you know you know that's
a dangerous that's a dangerous thing you
know if that happened it's just I mean
cuz think about it though cuz if he if
the people realize that they're getting
screwed over like they you know they
Hillary tried cheating in 2016 2020 was
some shady ass was it well well
think about this mic 20120 if I think he
lost I I hold on but but hear me out he
lost but but let me say my piece in 2020
the go the Democrats had 18 wait was it
40 or 50 FBI agents at Twitter no joke
had offices there working to stop any
negative stories about Joe Biden or
Hunter which they did a poll that they
said what percentage of people would
have not voted for Joe Biden if that
happened do you remember the number
there's a big number so so Mike but that
being said he still lost however they
played the game it's dirty game but he
did lose I was the biggest push and
that's why when you know Joe got the
amount of votes and Trump got the amount
of votes because I think everybody came
out I do not think everybody's coming
out again and I do not think like every
last American is going to vote fully
agree yeah but that being said this
narrative and also if there was some
somebody in Trump's here stop with the
fake election rigged election we we got
cheated last time you lost Muhammad Ali
lost to Joe Frasier in the garden 15
rounds everybody loses you got
to accept you got to he lost that that
election you know it's not like the
every single court and there's they they
they tried there's there's no proof of
it they got to move on from that and I
think it's a bad look for the Republican
party and it's ridiculous look for him
still be talking about that I mean I
think two things can be true at once
what Vinnie's saying about Twitter York
Post and the and the misinformation and
the disinformation the suppression that
is a separate conversation than the
actual counting of the votes if you want
to count the votes he lost if you want
to say well if it weren't for all this
these votes would have been different
and I think they pushed them in with the
vote you know the suppression going into
it but I think that's just part part of
the game it's like you know like if you
could get away with holding at the
offensive line you're holding but you
know I think they the the Russia rushia
Russia I think some of that was real in
the Facebook and all that but the
like this guy still sorry to
kurur he's still talking about the
rigged election I was like come on man
there's no rigged election but don't
forget he was also talking about a
rigged election when he won in 201 he
did it you live by the sword you died by
the sword a new script writer yeah but
but at the end of the day I mean he
doesn't trust any I wouldn't trust
anybody especially with 2016 but at the
same token at the same token I would
rather have nuts behind the wheel right
now than by the way let's say CEOs let's
say Pat there's two CEOs Mike you're a
CEO and he's a CEO would you rather have
a boss that is uh loud Brash whatever
but guess what the building is protected
we get paid or or ready for this
the guy that's talking nice but the
is on fire I want that guy but my I'm
not saying don't get me wrong that that
to me is electric interference is
they're cheating with Twitter but the
mailin ballot situation with all the
that I saw and that overnight jump
I'm just saying hold on can you blame a
guy for not trusting a party that was
cheating with Hillary on 2016 and he
still beat that that's why I don't
like when people say he's crazy he's
nuts I I don't think he is I think
that's the wrong is he an egomaniac is
he a narcissist is he thin skinned sure
all that but he's not crazy to think
that the media is after him he's not
crazy to think the Deep state is after
him
because they are yeah 100% okay so two
things again can be true one this is why
it's not black and white there's a lot
of gray area going on here there's a few
things that could happen that can make
his life very hard if the Border gets
fixed by the end of the year if they fix
it Trump's chances go lower if the
economy gets better dramatically gets
better that decreases his chances if
they shut down the border and they just
close it up and no more people coming in
it'll help hurt Trump
if they put in Nome and Michelle it'll
hurt Trump Michelle's not doing this you
know what they just did the last week
two weeks ago so Obama's side they they
send out fillers asking donors what do
you think about the you didn't hear
about this last week what do you think
about the the possibilities the
prospects of Michelle Obama would you
support her and Obama did that with
people out there do you have that story
Rob to pull it up of course they so so
to see what she would do because they're
trying to get somebody that can replace
Kamala they know they can replace Biden
they don't know how to replace Kamala
and if they had a Nome Michelle that's a
real interesting race there if they
announce at DNC it's n nsome Michelle
and Adam always says Vegas od's
president n is the president her is vice
what whichever one vice versa no she not
going to do Vice that's exactly what I
said she's not going to do the president
either because as cute as it sounds and
as egotistical as it sounds
she and her husband know that even if
she did snap her fingers and I think she
would win you have to do the job and she
does not want to do the job I think so
maybe why would she want him go back to
it Michelle Obama may have notified
people in 22 of her White House I plan
to run I don't believe it I don't
believe it I don't I think they know
they did this for eight years they know
the grind of it yeah oh yeah why would
she do it I've never been in the
Michelle Obama man camp I've never been
in the mama running for president Camp
let me ask you question let me ask you a
question how much of becoming a
president on the Democratic side hear me
out how much of being a president on the
Democratic side do you think is you
getting picked or you saying I'm going
to be a president you know what I'm
saying yeah okay how much of it do you
think is the first one over the second
one I I would oh go ahead Michael you
you getting picked so meaning for
example you and your wife K and we come
and we say hey we'd like to have a
meeting with you Thursday night at 7:00
yeah you take me for a nice meal and
we're going to say Michael you pick me
you but you send a car you send a car to
pick me up for the car's coming Mike you
come to our place private room Penthouse
we're sitting there you walk up Chef
anything you want we would know what you
like food tell us what you like nice
Sushi done what your favorite Sushi
okay restaurant yeah Noble I mean
there's a bunch of them no Sugarfish is
very Sugarfish is great just it's it's
straight down the middle other places
that are more exotic noo yeah you
call he's
confused what percentage you think the
party comes to you and says hey we want
you to run and you're going to run and
we got money for you that works for me
and my beautiful wife but we haven't
been president before so Barack and
Michelle Obama they know the grind
they're living they're producing on
Netflix want know where I'm going with
she gets to make a choice no I don't
think so see that's what I'm saying I I
don't I think they go yo we need you
you're going she she doesn't need
anybody to say we need you she
understands what's going on yeah but I
guess the question I'm asking guys the
question 640 pep you're saying 60401
saying 6040 The Establishment comes in
and says you've been chosen you're 40%
buying so so let's let's just say let's
just say they come to you by the way I'm
kind of with you I think it's
more them coming to you than I'm going
to go be a president I agree I think
there's a lot of guys that I'm going to
go be a president and you you don't even
know their first name yeah and they just
don't have it you can have the you know
aspirations are great but I'm going to
be an NBA star 6in vertical bro go right
go bowl you're going to be okay but okay
so if that's the case if Obama's were
chosen those same people that came
knocking on their doors and turn them
into a president two term are going to
come back and say look guys if you
believe in that now here's a second
second question what's the likelihood of
those same guys who are not your friends
they're not best friends with you these
are not the type of people that go to
dinner with you to get close to you yes
these are Power Players they
intentionally you will get the good meal
it's going to be very good food but
these are the guys that intentionally
keep distance from you so they can be a
bad person to you and you can't be any
emotional about it because listen we
don't have a relationship okay what are
the likelihood of them coming and saying
the following of this conversation
taking place
hey um Michelle it's party before
country and your party needs you right
now because if we don't Trump's going to
get elected and We've ran 200 surveys
We've ran the numbers we ran analytics
and the only two that works to win is
you as a president Nome as a VP we know
you don't want to do this because you
have a great life but if you don't
Trump's going to get elected and if you
don't those three things that nobody
knows
we would have to leak it we don't want
to but we would have to leak it we would
prefer to be easier we can have you only
be a one term but because after the one
term we can have somebody else come in
but we need you to come in right now
because we don't have anybody more
qualified than you to be the VP that's
the what do you think is the likelihood
I don't think that that would work with
her and and and Barack it's the two of
them it's not happening but but Mike I
think I think he who do you think right
now is running the Democratic party I'm
curious tell me why why do you think
because I think
that they have been there they've done
it they are living an incredible uh
successful life of retirement they're
celebrities and I think that Michelle
and Barack both of them know that they
would have to do this job that I think
they've already it's like going
backwards even though she wasn't the
president she I'm not doing this I
sat there and watched this this almost
killed my husband came in there lean
mean and mean they came out his like you
know he made it out looking better than
most but I mean they grade him up and it
takes a toll on you and I don't think
she's doing it their kids are adults I
think they're done I I just think
they're done still looks good but I mean
they take it it takes it so what do you
think I I I I personally think it's I
I'm I'm being dead ass Mike I think it's
the Hey listen Because if you think
about it who's in charge of the
democratic party who is it I think it's
Barack is up there Hillary's up there
who else would you put up there Adam
that's like behind the scenes that's
like yo like like listen this is what
we're trying to do the money Mone so so
so Mike I kind of feel where he's coming
from it's like like listen we know you
don't want it but guess what we need you
this is it because guess what this cat
is is Trump is almost a shuen if they
don't put him in jail if you don't we
are done and then he's going to expose
everybody I don't know here's here's how
I see it okay here's how I see it the
the way I see it is that that one happen
to an anti-establishment
candidate okay so what's an
anti-establishment candidate like I
don't think you can do that with uh you
know Kennedy I don't think can do that
with trumps I don't think can do that
with uh RFK I don't think can do I don't
think can do that with the
anti-establishment guy but the
establishment guy you know what they're
saying it's a you know vow hey party
before anything anything so if it's
party before anything that means if we
going to need you later on you're going
to have to come campaign you're going to
have to come do this and that includes
if later on you got kind of run again
because it's pretty bad cuz you know
what's going to happen if Trump gets
elected what do you know the first term
Trump got in what did he really do on
his first term what did Trump really do
to Hillary what did Trump really do to
anybody nothing really actually think
about how uh uh uh how you know how you
say his bark
is Lou than so so he said you'd be in
jail she never went to jail he never
went after her so he never did nothing
would you be concerned if if if Trump
got I know we're staying on Michelle the
potential but would you be concerned
with with all his resentment and anger
towards all these people uh if if he did
win that that would be his uh agenda uh
and it would sort of you know like you
know just get revenge on everybody if in
the following way if in the following
way if he gets in he'll fire aray he'll
fire he'll replace Powell he'll get rid
of a lot of guys that he doesn't like
that he sees as establishment and if he
gets the right people in that are able
to find out remember when the Twitter
files was coming out and we were
learning that the F was in on it and
they were saying you can't do this you
can't do that if we get the FBI Files if
we get CIA files meaning if somebody
goes in and shows like how dark it is in
these institutions and he finds out that
the baracks and the Hillary and the
Michelle he really really finds out I
think it's going to be Vengeance yeah if
it gets to that L is that good for the
country I don't think it is but what I'm
saying to you is if he goes in and just
wants to get the job done and he does
what he does with the economy and then
gets another person to come in and be
there for eight years great but for me
from the standpoint of ask the question
the other way ask the question the other
way what if he doesn't find out what if
another person from The Establishment is
still running America what if another
person from The Establishment is still
in the White House what do they do they
keep using the weapon the the the
Justice the doj to weaponize against
anybody they want and what does that
mean somebody you support later on a
candidate you support later on man that
is not a country you want to be living
in I it is not a place you want to be in
because at that point you your voice
doesn't matter right you're nobody at
that point so regardless he didn't do
anything on first term so you have to
ask why he either didn't do it because
he wanted to be softer on first so he
gets reelected mhm or he was just never
going to do it period it was just a
threat bar I think it was more of a
threat then if that's the case I think
he gets elected they're not going to do
anything but if you're Michelle if
you're Barack if you're Hillary if
you're the establishment on the left do
you think they believe that I don't
think they do no I don't think they
believe what you think no I think they
think he's going to go in and seek
Vengeance I yeah I think so you
understand what I'm saying if you
believe what you just said you do yeah
if you believe that they believe that
he's going to go to seek Vengeance then
Michelle has to go run and you you just
said too that you thought he might seek
Vengeance but you said if he got I I I
don't think he needs any more
information at this point to find out
yeah pretty blatantly obvious he's got
enough what he needs and you know he's
been you know everybody's going after
him you know uh uh some some valid some
not valid uh uh so he goes in there I I
don't think it'll be like like I don't
think he'll be that aggressive I think
he's going to come in like you said
fired you're fired you're fired but then
guess what though Michael I think he's
going to go 100% shut the border do like
he is going to come in again like Trump
wins if Trump wins I think he's going to
obviously fire the people that need to
be fired the people that were the the
the the cats that were like behind think
that's the question W I don't think
that's the question I'm telling you
that's not the question I think the
question is The Establishment left how
much do they fear Trump getting
reelected that he's going to do that a
lot well give me a score between Z to
100 100 okay perfect if that's the case
Michelle has to run I'm betting you 100
bucks I got 100 here that Michelle's not
running or press n do she ain't nothing
none of this she's producing Netflix
films yeah I I I listen it's an easy job
proding specific so Michael does not
think so you so she might run I'm not no
no she not running I'll do 100 just to
have fun I don't have but what I'm
saying to you is if if the left if the
left wants to win there's only two
people that's Vegas ODS right now by way
number one is Trump winning two is B
number three is Michelle Michelle was
they're saying Michelle is going to run
Vegas knows something and mind you
though Michael this was a couple months
ago she wasn't even on the top 30 bro 40
Michelle just jumped up that's crazy bro
I've heard that too I just don't still
it's still 11 to1 look is it in the
realm of possibility yes I I've been the
the the biggest uh proponent that she's
not running there's been no evidence of
running you know if if I could pretend
to be Joe Biden for a second and what do
you think the conver it's easy to say
he's a he's dementia it's easy to say
he's an old man it's easy to say he's a
cadaver it's easy to say he's not really
running the country but let's just role
play for a second if I'm Joe Biden I
don't even know if he has this kind of
oomph in him but if he's if he wanted to
say listen uh you Trump came in here he
tore down Obama's Legacy in 2016 there's
that video of Obama showing him around
the White House that was embarrassing
you guys ran Hillary Clinton lost you
tried to have Bernie Sanders come in
Lost I show up freaking Joe Biden I win
now again he's a little delusional here
this is role playing here so Michelle
Obama's never she's never been elected
for anything in her life she's never
been elected catcher all of a sudden
she's just going to manifest herself and
become president of United States if
there is a plan look at what's going on
Biden just won New Hampshire he won
Nevada he won South Carolina this plan I
think will un be unfold by super Tuesday
which is in 25 days from now March 5th
if he's still the candidate at what
point are we going to be like all right
I think Joe Biden is actually running by
you know what you know what I believe
that yeah a good point I believe that at
DNC so I will believe after August a
August yeah I will believe then that
you're right but I'm just telling you
the the answer to the question starts
with How concerned do you think the left
is 100% then if that's how concerned
they are they're not going to take an L
to say let's just take this L this year
and go get our draft picks and let's
kind of rebuild like you know what is
that one motto the 76ers had every trust
the process or whatever it was oh we're
going to just trust the process no no no
if you believe this is it cuz Trump's
not going to run 2028 say Trump loses
this year he think he's going to run 28
now he's out never know but the point is
if that animal you never know exactly I
would not rule anything Trump if you
think he's that formidable and you know
no one's ever won with their approval
rating being in the 30s that includes uh
Biden that includes Carter that includes
a bunch of guys that were in the 30s
that never got reelected then you cannot
sacrifice a election to give it up to
Trump you have to go to your bench and
you have a good bench with two players
two players you got there are good
players oh what you're saying is
completely normal it is not farfetched
at all I'm just this is the Henry
Kissinger Doctrine basically stop being
like a you have to think as a pragmatist
in reality not wishful thinking the
pragma the the pragmatic point of view
would be like he's running he's
announced his candidacy he's the
incumbent of the president of United
States he's running
the train has left the station they're
acknowledging how bad the PO
numbers are did you see wa do you have
that video bid M just just a comedian
it's just it's to the point where I feel
bad I'm not even trying to talk it's not
it ain't a good look for also it's it's
not a good look for the country or the
presidency and he's talking about Hamas
here right is this the one Rob P can we
thr this haven't seen look look at how
yesterday right he forgot about what
hamas's name was look at this there is
some movement and I don't want to I
don't want to some the
piece well me choose my words watch this
there's some movement there's been a
response
from the uh somebody has to yell it out
look look the there's been a response
look from the
opposition but um it yes somebody yell
Hamas blinking but it seems to be uh
dude a little over the top no listen
these guys that's sad that's sad let me
ask you a question as of
today and also I appreciated the way
that you you went at that dude that was
here that guy um B my good
friend bosam Yousef the comedian shout
out to you the comedian yeah but but um
how do you see this coming to an end uh
uh with with with with with Hamas and
and and and the hostages and everything
that we're dealing with how do I see it
coming to an end right now with with
with um you know Hezbollah uh the
hostages and and and what's going to be
the end of this let's let's wrap up on
this
topic we got prep for upstairs but
here's what I would say with that part I
think it would be good for Jews
if uh uh Biden doesn't get caught on a
hot mic saying you know uh f Netanyahu
go f yourself n he's he's F an idiot or
something he's an f and bad guy yeah so
you say that to Netanyahu Netanyahu
decides two days ago ceasefire dealers
off the table right okay cuz he knows us
doesn't have his back so then you have
to hope somebody else comes in that's
not happening right now cuz when it's
this deep in things there's not going to
be another person stepping in Iran is
publicly the the you know the the
leaders are saying hey you know we're
going to suspend our attacks on us uh
you know soldiers and bases okay so us
attacks 125 bombs in 85 locations or
something like that and then you got
these guys on the other side with Iran
who are doing proxy Galore Hamas hutis
you know
Hezbollah and they have Russia has their
back China has their back Iran has the
largest military in the Middle East
587,589
[Music]
independently a nuclear weapon with only
a billion dollars and it would take him
5 years you really are that naive to
believe that Iran doesn't already have a
nuclear weapon how naive are you to even
believe that and talk to us like as if
you have looked at every square inch of
Iran underground we just saw what the
Hamas buil underground what do you think
they're getting trained they're getting
trained by the professionals who are the
ogs in Iran that are teaching so we are
way too naive with Iran the only way you
can fight them
off the closest thing we had every
single time it was almost close to tapel
and then be there being a revolution is
Iranian the the Hezbollah leaders the
people at the top the K and those guys
you know who they fear they fear their
women they fear their kids they fear
sanctions they fear students they fear
not who you think they fear that's who
they fear and by the way interesting
data when they held hostages 50 students
this is during the Carter era you you
know how long they kept the hostages for
444 days you know when they released
these hostages a second after Reagan was
giving his inauguration speech a second
you kept him for 4 I think it's 444 days
right there they kept him for 444 days
50 hostages the moment a Reagan came in
they're like holy so Iran fears a
strong leader like Reagan and Trump they
fear it somebody that's like you do
something I will take gam solmani and
everybody else if you do this ever again
to the US troops ever again that's
number one they fear their women they
fear their kids they fear their students
they fear sanctions and that's what
Trump was pushing boom boom boom boom
boom but today with Hamas with Israel
unfortunately us uh the the leader at
the top is not showing that publicly
they're supporting them they're actually
showing uh uh I don't know man that's
not a good look there's no good look
when you see something like that and
they're watching there's no strength you
whatever you want you're right the only
thing Iran needs to know is one thing if
Iran knows us has Israel's back they
shiver 100% but they know they don't and
they're sitting there saying this is
awesome news Yep this is awesome news
the best news ever for them for Iran for
Iran not for you know it's great news
for them anyways
Michael really enjoyed it man this was
awesome this was amazing so we got two
bets we got two bet one the best here
big bets B our bet on camera is the
Knicks are making the finals they don't
have to win though Michelle and he's and
he's Michelle just running Mike he's
just just running we got a $100 bet the
fact that I came to this show and we
didn't discuss one thing about movies
barely anything about sports anything
else is astonishing to me because uh uh
the last I I just never thought that I
would be sort of dis having these kinds
of discussions because it's not
something that you know years ago was
like six seven years ago was in in my
wheelhouse of discussion so
changes become important anyways winning
bet Look At Me Now me winning Bets with
pbd Hey listen when you were growing up
in Yonkers you never dreamed that never
thought enough with this yoner all
right all right by the way Adam says
that Adam grew up in Miami in the rich
neighborhoods you know it's just a
schlepping over here hanging out the
best Jewish athlete in Miami have a
great one everybody take care we'll do
this again next week bye-bye bye-bye
that was great
awesome